tous les mois nous avions tout témoin
tout va mettre un peu de couleur d'avis
mais il est habitué à tourner et écrire
des sketches pour sa chaîne youtube dit
koch cumule aujourd'hui plus de 250
mille abonnés l'artiste s'est lancé un
nouveau défi réaliser un pilote d'une
série intitulée les aventures de bandits
goût de melun un jeune des quartiers
originaire de melun
il est persuadé que ça un chevalier il
va partir dans des croisades contre le
70 contre le contre le 94
il va lui arriver encore plein
d'aventurés de malades et on a on a
choisi de la choisit de 78 voilà la
verrière pour parce que voilà on a un
cadre idéal
l'idée c'est de voile a joué sur l'école
moderne anciens de la cité de 2,2 ce que
j'ai pu connaître aussi et s'amuser avec
et faire quelque chose de joyeux plutôt
que montrer tout le temps le même image
même image de la cité au dico chez son
équipe de tournage ont choisi la
verrière pendant cinq jours ils se sont
installés au coeur du quartier pour
enregistrer plusieurs séquences
notamment cette scène avec des cheveux
ou bondigoux rentrer dans ce fast-food
le tournage à la verrière un choix
facilité aussi par le producteur et
réalisateur originaire de la ville nadir
youlin l'idéal c'était quand même de
trouver un endroit où on a un quartier
populaire avec des bâtiments en
perspective est aussi un bois un lac
pour un peu dépaysé
et tout ça questions de logistique c'est
ce qu'ils avaient plus pratique le plan
artistique du conseil gestion ramener
les meilleurs les meilleures personnes
pour cet endroit là leur proposer dès
lors proposer des lieux qui conviennent
au scénario qui l'ont écrit donc comme
moi je connais parfaitement les lieux de
saint quentin en yvelines et là en
l'occurrence du bois de l'étang
je visualise les lieux je leur propose
les amendes sur les lieux ce tournage
l'occasion aussi pour nadir youlin et
son association pour la création et
l'innovation artistique et culturelle de
faire découvrir les métiers du cinéma
aux habitants de la verrière de son côté
dit koch prévoit la sortie du premier
épisode de sa série cet été sur sa
chaîne youtube dit que je t'ai b